I was just wondering how can I find a
job I'm passionate about without a
college degree well we got to find the
job first
the Direction first in fact it's less
about job it's more about path the type
of work is what I'm talking about and
then we go does it require a degree to
do that thing and here's what I want you
to do over the next 30 days I want you
to be very intentional to spend some
time in person or on the phone or Zoom
with with people that are in those
different fields find somebody who knows
somebody in that industry and just ask
them questions like you were doing a
high school term paper the reason is I
want you to get an idea of what their
Journey was get an idea of what they do
day in Day Out The Good the Bad and the
Ugly and the reason I want you to do
this is because it allows your head to
process this information and then your
heart kind of goes ding ding ding or
gives you that X sound